[Musique]
super crash annonçait depuis tant
d'années n'a toujours pas eu lieu
tu as plusieurs arguments pour défendre
que ça ce que ça n'a pas lieu pour que
ça a lieu il faut que suffisamment de
gens soient convaincus que ça va avoir
lieu et agissent en conséquence donc ça
c'est toujours comme ça autorisateur
c'est complètement autorisateur et
depuis 2008 les banques centrales ont
quand même sont beaucoup beaucoup
intervenus sur les marchés financiers à
différents endroits
pour les stabiliser et donc il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont convaincus de
ce qu'ils appellent un banquier central
put alors c'est un terme financier pour
dire que quoi qu'il arrive la banque
centrale sera là pour soutenir les
marchés là où ça pète parce que les on
sait que si les marchés s'effondrent
derrière il y a une crise économique qui
arrive déjà les banques centrales font
étendre d'éviter les crises économiques
ça fait partie des institutions qui sont
là pour essayer d'éviter les économiques
mais aussi
parce que les banques centrales savent
les banquiers centraux savent qu'on va
les blâmer eux ça on va trouver un moyen
de dire ah mais c'est parce que vous
avez
disrupté les marchés en 2008 en essayant
de les sauver il aurait fallu les
laisser s'effondrer pour que ça ça
nettoie le tu vois le cancers à droite à
gauche et gros parc sur de bonnes bases
ce qui est évidemment une bêtise c'est
complètement idéologique de penser ça
qu'il y aurait des cancers dans les
marchés que si on les nettoie ça marche
mieux les marchés sont chaotiques par
essence et c'est
voilà c'est tout et donc en fait il y a
ce double truc quoi un je veux pas que
l'économie s'effondre et deux je sais
que ça va me retomber dessus si je sauve
pas le petit jardin pour sauver le truc
mais donc ça veut dire que il y a des
moyens
d'éviter que l'économie française voilà
si tu dis qu'ils font tout ce qu'il faut
pour que ça se comprend pas l'économie
s'effondre parce que l'économie c'est
plus compliqué mais que les marchés
financiers s'effondrent ça oui tu as des
moyens pour le faire donc ça peut durer
indéfiniment alors faire te dire le truc
on a fini alors ça peut durer indéfinir
alors en fait le truc c'est c'est
toujours la même chose c'est ce qui
tient c'est vraiment le fait qu'il y a
suffisamment de gens qui sont persuadés
que ça va pas s'effondrer donc l'idée
c'est la banque centrale arrive et dit
mais moi j'achète x milliard de ça
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour parce
que X milliard ça va quand même faire
que 1% du total tu vois ou 0,5% du total
aussi ils font pas qu'ils font pas faire
100%
ou ce serait non ce serait la fin si il
faisait 100% donc il peut faire qu'un
certain pourcentage est-ce que le
pourcentage qui vont donner va être
suffisant pour combattre la masse de ok
c'est bon ils sont là pour nous pour
nous sauver et donc ça pour le moment
c'est suffisant mais peut-être que tu
arriverais à un moment donné ou même la
banque centrale ça c'est bon j'achète x
milliard les gens se disent non mais
quand même c'est pas possible et vendre
tu vois d'accord en fait c'est ça le
truc c'est que pour que les marchés
s'effondrent il faudrait que les gens
vendent en masse c'est ça qui est pas
d'acheter en face voilà c'est souvent ça
qui se passe c'est-à-dire que en fait
pour que tu aies un une variation de
prix très importante ce qui se passe
c'est que le mec dit ok ça va les
garantir donc aujourd'hui je décide de
vendre un 40 donc il va sur les marchés
il dit ok moi je veux bien vendre à 40
et là il y a personne qui dit je veux
bien acheter à 40 tu dis bah 39 alors
quelqu'un personne 38 37 bordel était 30
25 et là hop qui est 25 il trouve
quelqu'un donc le dernier prix c'était
25 donc maintenant tout le monde utilise
cette référence comme étant le dernier
prix et donc personne va proposer 40
maintenant on va tous tourner autour de
25 d'accord etc etc tu vois et ça
continue descendre mais alors du coup
voilà les gens vendent les marchés
s'effondre l'économie se crash mais
toujours ne disparaît pas non toujours
là non l'argent disparaît pas mais alors
ça c'est aussi un truc le sentiment de
richesse il vient pas nécessairement de
la quantité d'argent que tu as dans ta
dans ton portefeuille il vient aussi du
fait que tu dis bah j'ai je sais pas
cette table qui a une certaine valeur
j'ai ma maison qui a une certaine valeur
et donc j'ai des produits financiers qui
ont une certaine valeur mais tout ça
participe au sentiment de richesse et je
me dis si jamais j'ai un souci je peux
vendre ça je peux vendre ça je peux
vendre ça mais si je vois le prix de
tout ce que j'ai partir par terre je me
dis mais en fait je suis pauvre du coup
mon argent que j'allais dans ma poche
que j'étais ok pour dépenser bah
maintenant je veux plus le dépenser
parce que je me dis ça au moins c'est
sécurisé je ça perds pas de valeur je le
garde mais si je le garde comme les
dépenses des uns sont les revenus des
autres bah là ton économie est impactée
donc c'est ça le moyen de transmission
entre les marchés financiers qui sont
vraiment
fictif au sens de c'est juste la valeur
des choses qui existent et ces choses ne
disparaissent pas elles restent là et
l'économie où on fabrique des vraies
choses mais pour fabriquer des vraies
choses il faut des gens qui consomment
et des entreprises qui décident
d'investir pour fabriquer des trucs et
ça c'est vraiment ces psychologique quoi
quand elle voit que toutes les choses
perdent de la valeur perdent confiance
et elles veulent plus personne n'agit
plus personne veut se lancer dans
l'économie et ça ça crée ça crée les
crises quoi d'accord donc en réalité
pour qui est jamais de crise il faudrait
que les gens aient confiance en
permanence au marché en l'économie
continuer à investir en fait c'est ça
quoi c'est ça
aussi des dimensions qui sont physiques
au sens de tu as besoin d'énergie pour
fabriquer des trucs tu as besoin de
matières premières tu as besoin de gens
qui sont formés tu as besoin tu vois etc
donc il y a des tas de contraintes mais
une contrainte qui s'ajoute à ça c'est
effectivement le fait que tout le monde
a bien confiance tout le monde a envie
de dépenser tout le monde a envie de
tout le monde a confiance dans le
système
potentiels comme le covid
supplémentaire ou tu dis bah en fait
vous pouvez pas aller fabriquer des
trucs parce que sinon vous rendez malade
et donc on arrête de fabriquer des trucs
donc là ton économie est obligé de
ralentir tu as récemment je disais un
article sur un astéroïde qui contient un
potentiellement plusieurs centaines de
milliards de métaux précieux de se dire
un truc là il y en a pas mal je crois
mais celui-là en particulier
il représente plus que toutes l'économie
justement réunit toute l'économie
terrestre réunie et donc voilà il y a
des des ressources des matières
premières et évidemment il y a des
entreprises qui commencent à envisager
tu vois d'aller miner sur la stéroïde
mais admettons que ça arrive par exemple
admettons toutes ces ressources
démarches sur la terre qu'est-ce que ça
aurait comme impact sur sur l'économie
tout à coup les choses auraient moins de
valeur puisque on aurait beaucoup plus
bah tes matières premières pourraient
perdre de la valeur après c'est toujours
pareil des matières premières c'est
offre demande donc si ça ça commençait à
débarquer et que du jour au lendemain tu
as des tas de d'entrepreneurs qui
arrivent et moi du coup j'ai monté une
entreprise de ça une entreprise de ça en
fait tu pourrais avoir la demande que
augmente en même temps que l'offre et ça
sera
c'est possible faut toujours penser au
deux côtés du truc et après il faut voir
aussi que à chaque fois les financiers
ils essayent de lire l'avenir donc ils
se disent quel va être l'impact de ce de
ce truc là et c'est pas évident que tout
le monde arrive à la même conclusion
c'est le plus grand nombre c'est la
conclusion du plus grand nombre qui va
impacter les prix dans un sens ou dans
l'autre tu vois donc c'est c'est
tu es un peu comme avec le pétrole tu
sais où tu te dis s'il y a moins de
pétrole du coup l'économie ralentit
parce que l'économie est dépendant du
pétrole mais si l'économie ralentit
alors dans ce cas les entreprises qui
produisent du pétrole elles ont produit
trop par rapport à la demande mais si
l'offre est super à la demande alors le
prix baisse mais si le prix baisse alors
l'économie repart et donc du coup la
demande devient supérieure donc le prix
monte mais si l'offre est supérieur et
quand est-ce que tu t'arrêtes de
raisonner dans le futur et quand est-ce
que tu prends une décision sur sa moto
ça a baissé on est un épisode de plus là
problème
j'ai fait une un rassemblement
de plein de gens donnaient des
conférences et c'était un truc
c'était un truc d'entreprise donc
c'était quand même pas mal de frimes
c'était moi mon entreprise on va faire
des trucs super donc il y avait des gens
qui qui est Prométhée je suis pas
immortalité des trucs incroyables ils
sont juste très convaincus tu vois ils
sont plus convaincus que qu'ils ont
preuve et il y avait un gars justement
qui lui montait à une start-up pour
miner des astéroïdes
et qui était très optimiste très venait
investissez ça va être super et c'est la
première fois que j'ai entendu parler de
ça et c'est toujours des gens très
convaincants
on va on a on a des fusées on va envoyer
des sondes quand on aura détecté une
charge je sais pas de métaux
suffisamment important
qui va les miner des astéroïdes ça me
paraît être l'étape d'après logique quoi
pourquoi tu penses qu'on ne verra jamais
toi parce que c'est pas rentable du tout
de ouais non non ouais c'est trop cher
d'y aller ça vaut pas le coup ce qu'on
va en ramener vraiment il vaut mieux
juste ne pas y aller quoi en fait il y a
d'autres trucs qui peuvent être
intéressant c'est une minute de l'eau ou
des ressources qui peuvent servir à des
voyages spatiaux tu vois genre ça fait
une tour
[Musique]
c'est le fait de miner justement des
terres rares des trucs comme ça dans le
dans les abysses et ça c'est peut-être
un peu plus réaliste et à mon avis ça va
se faire pour le coup donc on va avoir
des mines dans les abysses donc ils vont
encore plus dévasté les les fonds marins
il y en a qui sont sur le coup je crois
que le Luxembourg est sur le coup
peut-être la Norvège ou la Suède je sais
plus mais ouais ça c'est en train de se
faire pour le coup c'est beaucoup plus
réaliste que d'aller miner des
astéroïdes
polymétaliques donc ça va être des
métaux des terres rares des machins
comme ça tu vois
des trucs qui nous servent pour les
technologies quoi et comment ça se fait
que on est toujours pas trouvé de
substitut au métal rare là tu sais pour
les téléphones là qui fait que il y a
des il y a des guerres comment s'appelle
coltan
tu vois
ne pas connaître le col d'entente
c'est ce métal rare là qu'il est miné
qu'un seul endroit sur terre donc Congo
comment tu as dit ah non c'est le col
temps
donc c'est un métorarissime et c'est ce
qui permet à nos téléphones de marcher
et ça alimente
des guerres au Congo
et on n'a pas de d'autres options
manifestement quoi et Charles villa il y
a pas très longtemps à faire un
reportage où il est allé dans les mines
de coltan il descend dans les galeries
donc évidemment il y a absolument aucune
mesure de sécurité les gars c'est des
gosses en plus qui mignent dans ces
trucs là meurent la plupart du temps
dans les tutelles parce que ça
s'effondre et donc c'est des des
tombeaux tu vois et quand ça arrive ils
font juste un trou ailleurs et donc
Charlie est allé il est descendu dans le
truc et quand tu vois la vidéo tu te dis
il va jamais en sortir quoi parce que
c'est hyper étroit et une fois arrivé au
fond de la galerie tu as deux pauvres
mecs là comme ça qui sont en train de
creuser leur truc et voilà donc c'est
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment l'argent
de la guerre et du sang quoi parce que
la des chefs de guerre évidemment qui
exploitent des gosses
et tout ça
ensuite alimente le marché des
téléphones et la question c'est comment
c'est possible qu'on n'ait pas trouvé de
substituer à ça comment on peut
continuer tu vois à entretenir cet enfer
et tu as des marques comme fairphone là
qui proposent des alternatives sauf que
c'est beaucoup plus cher parce que c'est
aussi pour ça que le col temps est
utilisé c'est que du coup c'est pas cher
et dans le reportage là tu vois tu vois
les gars qui expliquent que
en fait le prix c'est les marques qui le
fixent quoi Charles demande à un mec
mais bon ça se fait que le prix a baissé
de 20% d'une année à l'autre et tout ça
le mec dit bah nous on les vend au prix
qui nous demande en fait hein vous allez
vouloir à tel prix et ils vendent
donc voilà je suis content d'avoir fait
découvrir du coup
c'est cobaltanium je crois
le temps c'est Colombo et tantalite
bon
c'est ça exactement mais ouais mais tu
me demandes pourquoi il y a pas
d'alternative en même temps bah ça se
passe pas chez nous quoi comment c'est
possible que sur toute la planète on
n'est pas des minerais qui puissent
avoir la même fonction tu vois les mêmes
propriétés parce que je crois que la
propriété de du coltan là c'est que il
est il est très résistant à
l'humidité et donc il y a une histoire
de batterie dans la batterie il y a de
l'acide là et Ben se coltant résiste à
fond et c'est ce qui permet au gros
téléphone de de
de durée longtemps quoi
mais voilà je trouve ça fou que c'est un
peu comme le
vibranium dans les Marvel quoi un métal
qui n'existe qu'un seul endroit sur
terre mais ça tu as il faut il faut en
parler avec avec Rodolphe c'est le
rivière il a beau aussi pas mal sur les
les ressources métalliques alors il m'a
pas parlé de ce métal là mais par contre
lui ce qui me disait c'est que en gros
les terres rares c'est pas rare
c'est lui c'est pas de la terre c'est
pas rare donc c'est vraiment le nom le
mauvais et il disait en gros le problème
qu'on a c'est que pour l'instant il y a
quand même beaucoup de métaux comme ça
qui c'est des quantités infimes qu'on
utilise dans les téléphones ou dans les
dans les technologies en général et donc
en fait la production de ce genre de
truc elle est toute toute petite quand
tu compares à la quantité d'aluminium ou
de
comment de faire tu vois qu'on va
extraire de et donc en gros le truc
c'est que bah oui pour l'instant on mine
dans trois quatre pays qui a pas besoin
de plus c'est parce que c'est facile
d'aller là-bas parce qu'effectivement on
emploie des gamins et tout ce que tu as
cher donc on avait besoin d'une forte
quantité tu cherches limites en France
tu en trouves un bon et en gros l'idée
c'est que le donc déjà il y a pas besoin
de beaucoup ensuite il y a des pressions
enfin tu vois on peut pas ramener des
mines dans les pays développés parce
qu'on se dit bah les mines c'est un truc
pour les pays du Sud et pour les pays en
développement etc et aussi quand tu
regardes les parce que après tu dis
ouais mais il y a combien de je sais pas
moi de cobalt sur Terre par exemple tu
vas regarder des estimations mais en
vrai les estimations elles dépendent des
pays qu'on fait des analyses de leur sol
pour essayer de savoir à peu près
combien il y en a mais des pays qui font
l'analyse du sol sur le cobalt c'est que
les pays producteurs de communes donc
les trois quatre qui a et tous les
autres pays sont pas sondés et après si
tu fais par contre des extrapolations
par rapport à la ce que tu devrais
théoriquement pouvoir trouver dans la
croûte terrestre etc tu te rends compte
que il y a des quantités énormes et que
finalement il y a beaucoup de métaux
c'est donc en fait ce titanium là tout
ça là qui fait le col temps si on va le
chercher à la base c'est parce qu'il est
surtout pas cher bah moi je voyais ce
matin
au Canada aussi il pense en Egypte enfin
je sais pas si Wikipédia donc j'avais vu
aussi que c'est dans le dans le désert
sans Bolivie le désert de sel
ou univers de Yuni il y a la plus grosse
réserve mondiale de lithium et de la
Bolivie c'est un des pays les plus
pauvres du monde et l'idée c'était que
grâce au Salars tout à coup ça allait
devenir un des pays les plus riches
parce que le lithium est pareil c'est
pour les batteries quoi et je sais pas
où ça en est de ça mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que c'est sûrement pas la Bolivie
qui doit profiter de ses ressources et
ils ont dû être envahi par les pays
riches quoi
en tout cas pas les bolivier que ça
c'est après l'énorme problème de enfin
tu sais tu es tu as une ressource dans
ton pays mais tu as pas les
infrastructures pour aller les chercher
quoi t'as pas les entreprises tu as pas
les ingénieurs tu as pas les
connaissances tu es obligé de faire
venir les pays étrangers et là ils
arrivent et bon ils sont un peu
concurrents entre eux mais
potentiellement il discute entre eux et
tu vois il te pique quoi ça c'est
vraiment et puis si en plus le pays est
pas démocratique machin il laisse un
gros ticket au dictateur du coin et les
gens ils récupèrent rien derrière et là
tu Rebout sur la vidéo de celle-ci dupy
qui parle des comment tu gardes le
pouvoir dans une démocratie tu veux
rendre les gens heureux parce que ton
pouvoir dépend de mais dans une part
démocratie
qui dépend de l'armée quoi surtout qui
te maintient au pouvoir donc il y a
quelques
généraux à bien grassement rémunéré et
tout et
la ressource est principalement la
ressource naturelle que il t'a pas
besoin du peuple pour rejoindre la
richesse
à des niveaux de complexité il te montre
qu'en fait les pays démocratiques c'est
les pays où la le plus de complexité
dans la production c'est à dire que
vraiment les industries que dépendent
les unes des autres et du coup c'est
très difficile de contrôler l'ensemble
du système et donc du coup ça c'est ça
se prête mal à de la dictature alors que
par contre dans un pays qui se focalise
sur juste miner une ou deux ressources
bah ça c'est facile à contrôler c'est
pas trop compliqué et donc du coup ça se
prête très bien et donc ils font un
parallèle entre les pays qui sont peu
complexes et regardent les industries et
tout ils
font des des commandes des grilles de
complexité avec un score à la fin et il
montre que ouais les pays les plus
riches sont toujours les pays les plus
complexes dans leur dans leur production
centraliser l'information de ton
économie quelque part quelqu’un tu peux
tu peux la gérer ou est-ce que tu es
dans une dans un pays sophistiquée ou
chacun a ses propres contés compétences
et tu peux pas tu es obligé d'investir
dans des écoles qui font des formations
spécialisées dans tel ou telle domaine
et puis là du coup tu peux plus
contrôler
cet argument là il va un peu à
l'encontre de la tu sais Ricardo qui dit
chaque pays doit se spécialiser dans ce
dans quoi il est bon
bah le truc c'est que tu dis bah si tout
le monde fait ça tu as vraiment le pays
qui fait le vin le pays qui fait les
chaussures le pays qui alors justement
là le cette histoire de complexité
contredit ça en disant bah en fait non
si vous voulez devenir riche faut
vraiment plutôt essayer de faire un peu
tout plein de trucs parce qu'après ça va
être complémentaire sans même avoir un
projet de départ le fait de faire un peu
de ça un peu de ça un peu de ça et de
laisser un peu libre les entrepreneurs
ils vont trouver des passerelles des
connexions pour créer des nouveaux trucs
et en fait c'est comme ça que tu
t'enrichis que tu crées de la valeur
c'est une histoire de dépendance si tout
ton économie dépend d'un truc et si tout
d'un coup il y a plus d'intérêt pour le
truc
[Musique]
avec le pétrole là ils avaient ça ils
font que du pétrole enfin pas que du
pétrole tu vois mais beaucoup de
services et sinon du pétrole et donc du
coup pour avoir des services il faut
quand même des machines il faut des
biens il faut tu peux pas vivre que de
service quoi il te faut aussi du
physique du réel et donc le Venezuela
ils ont leur économie tertiaire où ils
ont beaucoup de monde notamment du
service public etc ce qu'ils peuvent se
le permettre et sinon tout ce qui est
production physique c'est pétrole quoi
pétrole tu vends l'international tu
récupères des dollars avec ces dollars
tu achètes tout ce dont tu as besoin hop
tu vas nourrir ta population sauf que si
tu entretiens pas bien tu es plus de
pétrole et que en plus le prix du
pétrole se casse la gueule et ben tu
peux plus acheter tout ce que tout ce
dont ta population a besoin pour vivre
donc tous les gens qui sont employés
dans les services du jour au lendemain
et leur argent sert plus à rien parce
que tu peux les continuer de les payer
mais ils vont dans le magasin il y a
rien dans le magasin ça se produit pas
et pour l'acheter il te faut des dollars
dollars que tu arrives pas à avoir
puisque tu produis moins de pétrole et
que le pétrole coûte moins cher et donc
ton pays il s'enfonce dans la crise
[Musique]